hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round 10 of the ftx
crypto cup
it was the last round that was played
yesterday uh last game and it's fabiano
corona versus anish girigiri was
leading the tournament uh for the well
basically for the entire day one and day
two and fabi is half a point behind and
he's trying to catch up
and this is a really great game it uh
it really shows how uh just you know
being a top elite player and knowing
everything is very very helpful
but also how uh how how simple chess is
when you
when you actually understand it and here
uh well basically
let's just see what happens and i'm sure
you guys are going to enjoy this one
so fabi has the white pieces and he
opens uh with e4
and basically what this game will be
about is uh you how how to win a game by
dominating one of your opponent's pieces
and you know just uh
this will be other and complete
dominance so here we have e5
knight to f3 uh knights this e6 and
bishop to b5 so just a normal rule lopez
here
we have a6 morpheus defense bishop a for
knight to f6 so nothing out of the
ordinary for the first like 20 moves
uh castles b5 just usual uh
roy lopez moves bishop to c5 we have c3
preparing to strike in the center we
have d6 and d4 and this
this has been played uh many times by
many strong grand masters
anish also had a head game against 11
aaron and the opera euro rapid where he
had the white pieces uh that game ended
in the draw
uh so you know they played with both
white and black so here we have bishop
back to b6
bishop to e3 and now we have castles
here and now
uh geary against uh levon went knight b
to d2 here but uh
fabi goes h3 so still not a new move we
have rook to e8 and
now knight b to d2 and here uh there are
some games where bishop to b7 was played
also knight to a5 is a known move just
making room for that c5 pawn but here we
have h6 by a niche
and already as of move 11 we have a
completely new game so let's see
uh how fabi plays this we have rook to
e1 a continuing development uh now the
rook will also help
out with the defense here we have e
captures c captures and
just knight to b4 now making room for
this c pawn but
also eyeing that d3 squared uh if you're
able to get your knight there you're
gonna
get a nice attack uh against the rook
and the b2 pawn here
uh but fabi doesn't care fabi just plays
d5 offers a trade of dark square bishops
and even
allows this knight to d3 and he allows
uh
uh anish to snatch a pawn here so here
we have knight to d3
right away it is the best move uh rook
to e2
saving the rook and now anish doesn't go
for the pawn
uh if you go for the pawn you're gonna
have to give it back for example queen
c2 and now
uh wherever you go we're gonna capture
this knight and the pawn as well for
example captures captures and captures
and this is fine for black but anish
decides to to keep the tension he plays
knight to h5 he wants to bring the other
knight to f4
and further harass this rook uh maybe
even force uh
force fabi to give up the dark square
bishop so fabi uh
grabs uh giri's dark square bishop uh so
he doesn't have to give it up for a
knight and leave this monster bishop
here on this diagonal
bishop captures with c captures in the
now rook to e3
anticipating knight to f4 so now if
knight to f4 we could play something
like queen b1 attack this knight here
maybe kick it away
and uh well play it from there and while
this isn't bad
anish decides to grab the pawn now so
knight captures on b2
queen to c2 by fabi and now knight to c4
so like i said
you're gonna have to give it a pawn back
captures captures and captures and then
now
b5 and uh well this
is very nice uh fabi just plays queen to
d4 and now we have
knight to f4 and now just rook a to e1
and if you look at the position now
this is basically what this game is
about look at this uh
we'll look at the gear is a dark square
bishop or rather
light square bishop the dark lights
where bishop i
meant to say that uh doesn't really have
anywhere to go this is covered this is
covered
this is covered and okay this is
possible but
the bishop will not be doing anything
there for for a very long time
so here we have knight the g6 he's
trying to prevent
e5 he wants to blockade the position
with knights to e5 but of course the
fabi just
executes e5 on the spot so the captors
we have a
capture fest here on e5 captures
captures and captures captures and
captures
and uh here okay the position simplified
a little bit but the
the idea remains the bishop still has no
squares the bishop
the rook now covers f5 so you don't have
this this is covered this
cover this is covered and you don't
really have a square for this slight
square bishop and
that's uh what fabi will now use to his
advantage the knight will completely now
dominate the this light square bishop so
here
uh well you could play something like
bishop to b7 and claim okay you're going
to push the pawn
at some point pushing the pawn is just
terrible for black for example queen to
d7 you're going to block the pawn
knight comes here then the knight comes
here or rather even better knight can
come here so you don't even allow black
to exchange
it then you can go knight to c5 and
that's just
terrible for black so instead after rook
captures on e5 we have bishop to d7
you have to play the bishop somewhere
but now knight to b3 we're still getting
to that c5 square
queen to f6 uh and now knight to c5
attacking the bishop here we have rook
to d8 anish defends it and now
queen to e4 again with a terrible threat
of just picking up the bishop if
if anish does something weird here we're
just going to pick up the bishop and
deliver checkmate as the queen covers
the h7 square
so instead after queen e4 we have g6 and
now
okay now you uh you gave the king some
breathing room but you also weakened the
position a little bit now
fabi could also look into ideas like
maybe queen d4 with ideas of just
check and uh you know uh the queen on f6
is now undefended
uh but he goes for something else he
plays g4 uh further limits the
the movement of this light square bishop
king the h7
and now rook to e7 now threatening to
win the bishop
uh so bishop the c8 and now rook to c7
so what do you play here uh well you
constantly have to worry about
moves like knights to e6 coming because
the f pawn is pinned
so here uh giri un pins and now king to
g2
fabi starts improving the position of
his king we have h5
and now queen to f3 now offering the
queen trait and fabi is now very happy
to go into this end game
because the light square bishop is just
non-existent here and you you will never
be able to capture this pawn because now
the bishop is actually hanging on c8 if
the rook moves
so here king g7 and now knight to e4
now fabi uh force is a queen trade uh we
have queen captures
uh in the now king captures we have h
captures and g for h
captures and again uh this is not
possible because the bishop would just
hang
so bishop to d7 but now again knight
to c5 again harassing this bishop and
here you really don't have a move if you
play something like bishop back to c8
just d6 and we're gonna win this bishop
now next move we're gonna play d7
and that's it game over and of course uh
if you capture them we're just gonna
capture your bishop here
uh so instead after this knight to c5
move uh anish says all right
there there are basically no no moves i
can play here with my bishop
playing something like a bishop here
runs in tonight's the e6 check the f
pawn is pinned we're gonna lose the rook
here
so i might as well uh grab two pawns for
this for this bishop so finally bishop
captures on g4
and that's it that's what this bishop
accomplished this game
for the entire game it was just you know
hiding on c8 and d7 and c8 and d7
and now for the lack of a better move uh
you have to give it up for for two pawns
which
is not bad uh so here we have king
captures and now
rook captures on d5 and now anish has
two pawns for the piece but
uh you know if if maybe his position was
a bit more active maybe you could use
that better
but here it's going to be very hard with
f4 by fabi
and now king to h6 uh you can't really
play something like rook to d to go
after this because you might run into a
mating net for example 96
check now if you go king to f6 knight to
g5 and now for example this will be
checkmate so you'd have to go back then
we pick up
pawns with check then for example this
we go after these pawns
and then doesn't really matter for
example captures captures with check
we're going to move the rook and we're
going to push this pawn
it's going to be a very very easy
victory for fabi so instead after f4 we
have king to h6 saying that okay
you cannot really capture this because
your knight would hang but now
king f3 uh we have f5 by far
by geary king the e3 rook to d6 now
defending the the da6 pawn and now
rook to a7 with a double attack here we
have rook to c6 now if rook captures
then we can capture the knight
and if the knight captures then you can
just play rook to c3 with
check and then uh you you will be able
to
for example rook to c3 check king to d4
rook to a3
and now well now there's uh there's this
so not really not really much to look at
and if you play something like
uh uh well you could try something like
king to c5 we're going to play rook
captures on a2
and now when you start pushing these
pawns you will have excellent
drawing chances so instead after rook to
c6 we have just kinked a d4 by fabi
and now rook to d6 with check we have
king the e5
and it was uh in this position that
anish geary resigned the game
as now it is uh uh well uh it's really
unplayable uh pawns will start falling
and uh there's just not much you can do
here for example
if you go something like this then even
knights the seas
knights the e6 is possible and uh you
you have to be very careful here
because for example knight g5 is coming
and then you might have uh
you might have real real problems here
but it's uh
you don't even have to go for checkmate
you could just start start collecting uh
pawns and the geary doesn't really have
any any active moves to
uh to play here so really a wild one and
really shows you how
how simple elite chess is and how you
can take down
uh such a strong opponent like an
ishgiri
by seemingly doing not all that much
basically just dominating the
the light square bishop for for the
entire game as
for here after b5 like we said all of
these squares were
taken and the light square bishop
couldn't find a single square
for for the rest of the game in the end
you had to sacrifice it for two pieces
yeah also a very very interesting
concept maybe you can use it in some of
your own games
so you know uh hope you hope you got
something out of this one i thought it
was a a very nice game to show
and also uh so we don't forget these are
the standings after the first 10 rounds
giri was leading the tournament but now
uh after he was beaten by fabi fabi
takes the lead or rather
fabiano caruana temur rajab and hikaru
nakamura share first place with six and
a half points
then anish and wesley with six uh
svidler magnus and maxine bashar lagrave
with five and a half
those are the top eight and then okay
ding also with five and a half in ninth
uh in tenth uh with four and a half
yanipanishi and
uh levon arun uh on twelfth uh
dubois and grishchuk uh furuja and duba
with four
uh then grisha with three and p shot
with
a point and a half so he did grab some
of the points
so we'll see one more day of rapid and
then we'll see who qualifies for the
main event
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh
always try to dominate your opponent's
pieces if you can
uh i would like to thank mr hoody guy
boris davana shah and aman patel
uh barry mcmurdock and pratamish mahajan
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing with
this wonderful tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day